[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit jona
pareigis guten abend und herzlich
willkommen alles wichtige vom sport hat
norbert lehmann für sie deutsche familie
unsere themen heute im überblick
rezepte gegen die vierte welle
gesundheitsminister sparen wir möglichst
viele booster impfungen und immer mehr
länder verschärfen ihre regeln für
ungeimpfte
ohrfeige für us-demokraten sie verlieren
eine wichtige gouverneurswahl bei
präsident beiden bisher nicht geliefert
hat glauben beobachter
und mit offensiver wucht nach dem 5 zu 2
der bayern gegen lissabon in der
champions league schwärmt trainer
nagelsmann von seinen angreifern
weitere beschränkungen für nicht
geimpfte seien möglich so die scheidende
bundeskanzlerin denn die korona lage
spitzt sich zu wie man die zahlen runter
kriegen kann darüber beraten ab morgen
die gesundheitsministerin und minister
von bund und ländern heute haben schon
mal ärger chef wieder und noch
bundesgesundheitsminister sparen ihre
einschätzung abgegeben aber der
spiekermann berichtet
jens spahn ist ein minister auf abruf
und schwere kritik booster für alle
hatte er recht plötzlich vor einigen
tagen gefordert und damit erst gestern
ärztevertreter und die ständige
impfkommission gegen sich aufgebracht
deren leitlinie die über 70-jährigen
zuerst und die mit vorerkrankungen für
spahn ist das alles nicht schnell genug
wir haben im august
im august
gesagt in einem folge beschluss auch die
über 60 jährigen sollen ein
entsprechendes angebot bekommen es muss
nicht jetzt schnell gehen es muss
eigentlich schon seit einigen wochen
schnell gehen in den praxen könnten bis
ende dezember 15 millionen menschen über
70 zum dritten mal geimpft werden auch
der einsatz von mobilen teams und
impfzentren sei wichtig so wie wir jetzt
vorgehen 150.000 menschen am tag impfen
da bringen wir uns die booster impfung
diesen winter dann eigentlich gar nichts
da müssen das müssen wir wieder auf ein
sehr hohes niveau bringen so wie zu
hochzeiten der der impfkampagne wer
verantwortlich sein für steigende zahlen
und starke klinik belastung dafür hat
der chef des robert koch instituts eine
erklärung die vierte welle entwickelt
sich leider genauso wie wir es
befürchtet hatten weil nicht genug
menschen geimpft sind und weil maßnahmen
wie die asl regeln sowie die 2g und 3g
regeln nicht mehr ausreichend umgesetzt
werden uni klinik jena in thüringen nach
angaben der ärzte werden im moment hier
auf der intensivstation vor allem
ungeimpfte behandelt das personal an der
grenze planbare behandlungen müssen
wieder verschoben werden personalmangel
ein seit langem bekanntes problem dass
wieder sparen noch die länder gelöst
haben einen erneuten lockdown schließt
sparen aus zumindest für geimpfte und
genießen schon nächste woche könnte es
einen bund länder gipfel geben
viele krankenhäuser sind also wieder an
der belastungsgrenze
2220 cupid patientinnen liegen aktuell
auf intensivstationen so viele wie seit
anfang juni nicht mehr bundesweit wurden
laut lka 20 1398 neue corona fälle
binnen 24 stunden registriert das sind
2008 114 weniger als vor einer woche
194 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
kobe 19 innerhalb eines tages die sieben
tage incidents liegt bei
146,6 allerdings können die zahlen wegen
des feiertags in einigen bundesländern
noch verzerrt sein
auf die hohen corona zahlen reagieren
mehrere bundesländer jetzt mit
schärferen maßnahmen beispiel baden
württemberg wo sich die inzidenz im
letzten monat verdoppelt hat ab heutige
dort wären nicht geimpft oder genesen
ist braucht für vieles einen negativen
pcr test unter anderem bei restaurant-
und kinobesuchen und auch in der kantine
und für ungeimpfte gibt es wieder
strenge kontakt beschränkungen ein
haushalt plus höchstens fünf weitere
personen sandra susanka hat mehr
lange schlangen heute vor den corona
testzentren in stuttgart die meisten
wollen noch den normalen schnelltest mit
dem sie auch weiterhin zum friseur oder
ins nagelstudio dürfen von einem pcr
test wissen nur wenige ungeimpfte ich
bin es gut was sehr wichtig auch für die
anderen hat die sicherheit einfach für
mich als freiberuflicher ist das nicht
zu tragen also ich find die politik gibt
viel zu viel druck auf einzelne nicht
geimpfte aus für die ungeimpften kann es
teuer werden der test kostet zwischen 50
und 200 euro ist 48 stunden gültig nur
mit pcr test dürfen sie ab heute ins
restaurant kino schwimmbad museum oder
kantine außerdem haben sie diskotheken
verbot und kontakt beschränkungen ein
haushalt darf sich ab sofort nur noch
mit fünf weiteren personen treffen alles
maßnahmen damit die intensivbetten
belegung nicht noch weiter steigt
die belastungsgrenze
gastronomen birgit group glaubt nicht
dass gäste einen pcr-test machen nur um
essen zu geben sie ist jetzt das
wichtigste dass es keine schließungen
gibt wir haben würde ich sagen 95
prozent geimpften gäste wo viele schon
gesagt um das es sich impfen lassen von
den party übrig waren aber ich glaube
gerade für weihnachtsfeiern und
dergleichen wird sicher einiges studiert
werden für geimpfte genesene kinder und
jugendliche bis 17 jahren ändert sich
nichts sie sind von den verschärfungen
ausgenommen
in den usa ist jetzt auch der weg frei
kinder ab fünf jahren mit biontech
pfizer zu impfen die gesundheitsbehörde
gab dafür grünes licht us präsident
biden sprach dabei von einem wendepunkt
im kampf gegen die pandemie bereits ab
heute können jüngere kinder geimpft
werden die impfkampagne soll dann in den
kommenden tagen richtig anlaufen
um die auffrischungsimpfung in
deutschland geht es heute bei heute live
auf ihre fragen warten bayerns
gesundheitsminister holetschek und die
präsidentin der gesellschaft für
immunologie fall um halb acht in unserer
app und auf unseren social kanäle
schauen wir jetzt auf die spd denn die
ist auf der suche nach einer neuen
parteispitze nachdem norbert walter
borjans seinen rückzug angekündigt hat
otto chefin saskia esken auch abtritt
ist noch nicht klar am montag will die
spd-führung klarheit schaffen und einen
fahrplan und kündigen ein name der als
neuer parteichef die runde macht ist
lars klingbeil derzeit noch
generalsekretär
es ehre ihn dass sein name genannt werde
sagte er dem redaktions netzwerk
deutschland es handle sich um ein
reizvolles und
klingt zeigt sich also offen chacon
talabani wofür steht king weil er gilt
in der spd als einer derjenigen die den
gelungenen versöhnungsprozess mit
moderiert haben in dieser einst tief
zerstrittenen partei und er ist
verantwortlich gewesen für die
erfolgreiche wahlkampagne die die spd
jetzt wieder ins kanzleramt führen
könnte außerdem stünde er für einen
generationenwechsel an der parteispitze
und das alles qualifiziert ihn natürlich
für höhere ämter allerdings ist eben
noch unklar ob er überhaupt möchte dazu
hat er sich noch nicht ganz klar
geäußert vielleicht auch deshalb weil
noch nicht klar ist wer denn die frau an
seiner seite sein könnte die damit in
die doppelspitze kommt denn das scheint
schon ausgemacht zu sein dass die spd
weiter auf eine doppelspitze setzen wird
schnell soll es auf jeden fall gehen die
spd möchte tatsächlich bis montag klären
wer für eine doppelspitze zur verfügung
steht da tag nämlich der parteivorstand
und könnte dann schon einmal zwei namen
nennen dankeschöns akutell ab lg
weil es den gesetzlichen
krankenversicherung an geld fehlt will
der boden für das kommende jahr seien
extra zuschuss verdoppeln um weitere
sieben milliarden euro um die beiträge
stabil zu halten
insgesamt sollen die krankenkassen dann
28 5 milliarden euro kriegen das
beschloss heute das kabinett jetzt muss
noch der bundestag zustimmen
für us präsident joe biden gab es ein
dreiviertel jahr nach seinem amtsantritt
einen wichtigen stimmungstest ergebnis
ein herber dämpfer denn seinen
demokraten haben den gouverneursposten
im bundesstaat virginia verloren und die
republikaner und ihren kandidaten gelenk
in ein echtes warnsignal für joe biden
und seine partei vor den kongresswahlen
im kommenden jahr claudia bertz
berichtet
jubel denn glen young ins strategie ging
auf die themen steuern wirtschaft
natürlich kritik an jeder masken pflicht
und bitte kein zu kritischer umgang mit
dem thema sklaverei im
geschichtsunterricht kultur kampf das
zieht jetzt
gemeinsam verändern wir das ziel für
unseren stark
und freunde diese transformation
beginnen wir an tag 1
die demokratischen gegner haben ihn mit
trump gleichgesetzt haben den tramp
ismus bekämpft aber die strategie ist
gescheitert
obwohl trump in unterstützt hat bin ich
gar nicht sicher dass yang qin wirklich
ein tramp ist ist es ging einfach
komplett gegen beiden und darum aus
gehässigkeit alles zu machen was beiden
und seiner politik schadet
der präsident war für den demokratischen
kandidaten mcauliffe keine hilfe seine
zustimmungswerte im keller wut bei den
wählern dass noch nichts von seinen
großen ankündigungen bei ihnen
angekommen ist seine große
gesetzespakete bisher an
innerparteilichen kritikern gescheitert
für nikolov war der gegenwind aus
washington ein sturm
hier hatte er noch hoffnung schriftlich
gratuliert er später dem wahlsieger
längst richtet sich der blick auf die
kongresswahlen im nächsten jahr nur wenn
es den demokraten bis dahin gelingt für
die bürger spürbar etwas zu erreichen
haben sie eine chance ihre mehrheit im
parlament zu verteidigen
für angela merkel sind es die letzten
tage ihrer amtszeit heute ist sie noch
einmal in frankreich ein abschiedsbesuch
präsident emanuel marco empfing die
kanzlerin nicht wie üblich in paris
sondern im bau nach einem rundgang
sollen ein klavierkonzert und ein
privates abendessen folgen auch den
verdienstorden der ehrenlegion
frankreichs höchste auszeichnung will
man von seiner freundin wer merkel nennt
überreichen
nach äthiopien von dort gibt es berichte
über neue schwere
menschenrechtsverletzungen
es geht um den norden des landes soll
die region t3 dort kämpfen
regierungstruppen seit einem jahr gegen
rebellen in dem konflikt müsse auch
eritrea mit un menschenrechtlerinnen und
menschenrechtler haben dokumentiert dass
alle seiten heftige verbrechen begingen
nicht zuletzt die soldaten von abu ahmed
dem äthiopischen regierungschef und
friedensnobelpreisträger sofort von
lojewski
es sind seit wochen die gleichen bilder
zerstörte gebäude explosionen menschen
in panik tote nach einer kurzen
feuerpause fliegt die äthiopische armee
wieder luftangriffe auf die
kreishauptstadt mobile äthiopien spricht
von militärischen zielen die kreis
regionalregierung dagegen von lokalen
gebäuden und zilien der krieg in t3 ist
von extremer brutalität geprägt so das
ergebnis des un berichts heute
das auch wenn unser bericht nicht
explizit sagt dass die äthiopischen und
eritreischen streitkräfte die größte
verantwortung für
menschenrechtsverletzungen tragen haben
wir genügend und belastbare aussagen zu
vermuten dass das tatsächlich der fall
war
auch die soldaten der täglichen
befreiungsfront tplf allerdings haben
ihren anteil sie feiern die
gefangennahme äthiopische soldaten heute
und tötungen geht es auch hier
äthiopiens premier ahmed erst unlängst
vereinigt verhängte gestern den
landesweiten ausnahmezustand rief die
bevölkerung zu den waffen
wir müssen die verteidigung stärken
nicht nur wegen der tpf wer nicht haben
wir es mit feinden zu tun die dieses
land zerstören das abu ahmed 2009 10 den
friedensnobelpreis bekam halten
inzwischen viele für einen fehler
vielleicht sieht der normalerweise
darauf ab akteure zu inspirieren oder zu
ermutigen positiver zu handeln das hat
sich nicht immer so wie heidi biebl
jetzt
über fünf millionen menschen den t3 so
das welternährungsprogramm sind auf
hilfe angewiesen die fronten aber sind
zu verhärtet und alle wege für die
konvois blockiert
facebook reagiert auf kritik und schafft
die gesichtserkennungsfunktion ab mit
ihr konnten gesichter auf hochgeladenen
fotos automatisch erkannt und den namen
markiert werden facebook kündigte an
dafür daten von mehr als einer milliarde
menschen zu löschen als grund heißt es
es gebe wachsende gesellschaftliche
bedenken gegen die funktion zudem
fehlten klare regeln der
regierungsbehörden
für die staatliche förderbank kfw
läuft's wieder bestens in den ersten
neun monaten dieses jahres machte sie
einen außergewöhnlichen gewinn von fast
zwei milliarden euro nach einem
gewinneinbruch im vergangenen jahr
spd grüne und fdp wenn das sicher gerne
hören denn sie setzen unter anderem auch
auf investitionen der kfw um ihre
geplanten regierungsvorhaben umsetzen zu
können mehr dazu von stefan schlosser
die wunschliste der möglichen neuen
regierung ist lang zig milliarden sind
nötig für die bewältigung des
klimawandels für digitalisierung für
bildung und vieles mehr problem nur die
schuldenbremse schränkt den spielraum
erheblich ein steuererhöhungen schließe
die fdp kategorisch aus das geld muss
woanders herkommen zum beispiel von der
staatlichen förderbank kfw gut bei
dieser konstruktion gibt der staat nicht
einfach geschenke also subventionen an
die unternehmen sondern er beteiligt
sich an konkreten projekten sei es über
kredite oder sei es über echte
eigenkapitalbeteiligung das heißt der
staat ist dann aber auch an diesen
projekten deren erfolg auch langfristig
beteiligt das heißt wenn sie gut
funktionieren dann verdient der staat
und die steuerzahlerinnen steuerzahler
wird tatsächlich am ende langfristig
sogar geld läuft es allerdings schlecht
haftet der staat auch für verluste viele
der nötigen investitionen und vor allem
das damit verbundene risiko wären für
private geschäftsbanken zu groß die kfw
gehört vollständig der öffentlichen hand
mit bund und ländern im rücken kann sich
das institut fast zum nulltarif
verschulden vielen ökonomen gerät aber
vor staatlichem einfluss der staat sei
nicht der bessere unternehmer und das
umgehen der schuldenbremse über die kfw
außerdem gar nicht nötig meines
erachtens sind die mittel die die
schuldenbremse in den kommenden jahren
für investitionen eröffnet hinreichend
groß es sind ja schon heute 50
milliarden euro pro jahr an statt
investitionen im bundeshaushalt in der
mittelfristigen finanzplanung eingeplant
und die muss man dann zusammen mit dem
eu programm erst einmal überhaupt
verausgaben können das problem der
vergangenen jahre war er der zögerliche
mittelabfluss und nicht die tatsache das
geld gefehlt hätte die angehende
koalition hat große pläne teure pläne
und sie scheint fest entschlossen mittel
und wege für deren umsetzung zu finden
gut 15 jahre lang war joachim löw
fußball bundestrainer
für seine verdienste wurde er heute vom
bundespräsidenten auf schloss bellevue
geehrt beim mittagessen im kleinen kreis
dankte frank walter steinmeier löst man
wolle ihn nicht einfach von der bühne
gehen lassen als sei nichts gewesen löw
habe dem land viele momente geschenkt
wie die weltmeisterschaft 20 14 der 61
jährige war im sommer zurückgetreten
so wir bleiben im fußball kommt zur
champions league norbert uns den beiden
deutschen 7 grad fangen wir mit den
bayern ja ein glänzender auftritt gegen
benfica lissabon allen voran von
münchens tormaschine robert lewandowski
dreimal traf er beim souveränen 5 2
heimsieg bayern damit vorzeitig im
achtelfinale
julia nagelsmann hatte sein team sehr
offensiv aufgestellt und aus dieser
angriffslustige 11 starten drei spieler
besonders hervor an erster stelle der
immer noch torhungriger robert
lewandowski der seinen hundertsten
champions league einsatz mit drei toren
krönte dann sicher auch der stets
unberechenbares herrscht in ambri mit
einem herrlichen hackentrick treffer und
nicht zuletzt der in dieser saison
regelrecht aufgeblüht die heussallee mit
einem besonderen technischen hingucker
hat
viel spaß gemacht die behörden also
bestes tennis spiele auch das beste
spiel völlig der letzten wochen im
nationalen pokalwettbewerb krachend
ausgeschieden stehen die bayern
international nun schon in der runde der
besten 16 teams
ja und ebenfalls siegreich die bislang
in dieser champions-league-saison
sieglosen wolfsburger neuer trainer
neues glück florian kuckels
internationale premiere mit dem vfl 2 2
1 gegen salzburg die chance aufs
achtelfinale gewahrt großen anteil an
florian kopp als erstem erfolg in der
champions league haben riedle baku und
der zweite u-21-europameister im team
des vfl lukas matcher glücklos dagegen
für salzburg der dritte deutsche u
21-europameister adeyemi nachdem er früh
vergab trifft auf der gegenseite rite
backen zum 1 0 für wolfsburg
noch vor der pause gleich rüber für die
vor zwei wochen mit 3 zu 1 gegen
wolfsburg siegreichen salzburger aus
nach einer stunde dann aber lukas
manager der 22-jährige mit der woche und
der entschlossenheit eines echten
stoßstürmers einer spezies die in
deutschland bereits ausgestorben
schienen genau so einer könnte auch der
nationalmannschaft gut tun
ja und heute abend spielen noch dortmund
und leipzig die zusammenfassung der
partien vom vierten spieltag zu sehen
bei uns ab 23 uhr im sportstudio
champions league bei zdf heute.de und in
der zdf- heute- app
und nächste überraschung beim atp
tennisturnier in paris durch dominik
koepfer nach seinem furiosen auftakt sie
gegen andy murray schlägt er in der
zweiten runde auf den weltranglisten
elfter felix i alias ihn aus kanada
töpfers erster matchball sitzt und er
sieht mit 6 zu 3 7 zu 5 und steht im
achtelfinale
gleich steigt auch die deutsche nummer
eins alexander zverev ins turnier ein
dazu morgen mehr dankeschön hat und wir
schauen noch auf die lottozahlen die
gewinnzahlen lauten 10 13 14
28 44 49 und die superzahl ist die 0
weitere gewinnzahlen finden sie auf
lotto punkt zdf.de und im zdf text auf
seite 5 157
heute nacht fällt am alpenrand schnee
und der tag morgen wird für einige
ziemlich verregnet auf was sich genau
einstellen sollten erfahren sie gleich
von katja hall war das heute journal
können sie um 21 45 sehen mit claus
kleber
[Musik]
guten abend in den alpen ist der winter
bereits da wenn sie genau hinschauen
dann sehen sie hier weiße flächen die
sich nicht bewegen das ist schnee sie
sehen aber vor allen dingen die wolken
die von süden nach norden ziehen und auf
dem atlantik ziehe diese schau wolken
von norden nach süden stauten sich am
kantabrischen gebirge da regnete es
deswegen kräftig kräftige regen fiel
auch heute und in der nacht fällt wieder
schnee an den alpen aber auch im
schwarzwald oberhalb von etwa 800 metern
sonst regnet häufig im norden ist es zum
teil auch trocken und hier im nordwesten
zu rund um münster oder osnabrück da
kann es auch mal für nebel oder dunst
reichen denn dort sinken die
temperaturen auf zwei grad genau sowie
am alpenrand sonst bleibt die nacht bei
7 bis 4 grad milder und morgen erwarten
uns höchsttemperaturen zwischen 5 grad
an den alpen und maximal 10 grad in der
lausitz oder auch an den küsten von
nord- und ostsee das wird ein sehr
regnerischer donnerstag und am
heftigsten schützen wird es zwischen der
ostseeküste und dem erzgebirge schon am
vormittag lassen die schnee- und
regenfälle am alpenrand nach und
zwischen nordfriesland und dem sauerland
da bleibt es am ehesten trocken die gute
nachricht zum schluss ist das wetter
beruhigt sich zum wochenende und wir
sehen dann häufiger mal die sonne bei
temperaturen von fünf bis zwölf grad
guten abend